I've got one more surprise
for everyone.
My wife baked a batch
of her famous
ooey-gooey butterballs
for the office.
[ All murmuring ]
Take one and just
kind of pass it around.
You are gonna get messy because
these are no joke.
Christian: John.
Enough.
Your wife's
ooey-gooey butterballs
can wait until
after the meeting.
I'm so sorry, Christian.
So sorry.
But don't worry,
everyone,
they're even gooey-er
when you wait.
And back to Christian.
Now, what I was about
to say was
I bought BNN.
It was a $10 billion deal.
The media said it was
impossible.
Congress said
it was "illegal."
But through sheer force of will,
I made it happen.
Okay, then.
John, go ahead and, uh,
pass out your wife's
little treats.
Yes, sir. [ Laughs ]
All right, everyone,
come and get it.
Now, warning, these are
extremely gooey.
One of these is vegan.
I couldn't tell you which one.